we're often asked the question which
platform and makes sense to use for
profiling a beat array or sequencing
almost always cost is the biggest factor
so you'll primarily need to strike a
balance between cost and performance and
additionally individual goals of your
project will also heavily influence
which team if that makes more sense in
this video we're going to discuss which
method makes more sense for which
situation and why in some situations
both methods make sense and they can
even complement each other before making
the decision to go with RNA sequencing
or micro arrays several questions must
be answered first are the practical
questions such as what genome
information is available if any for my
species of interest how much data
analysis expertise do I have or have
access to and perhaps most important how
much money do I have to spend equally as
important factors in making this
decision are the goals of the project
beyond just measuring differences in
gene expression between samples it's
accurate absolute quantitation important
is it important to discover novel genes
do we want to be able to distinguish
isoforms and the expression difference
between the isoforms am i interested in
transcripts likely to be expressed at
very low or very high levels and finally
am i interested in structural
information such as alternative splicing
and gene fusions once these questions
have been answered you can be confident
you have selected the appropriate method
to achieve success in your project
before comparing methods let's take a
moment to discuss the similarities
between the two
first both platforms demonstrate a high
run to run reproducibility and there is
a high correlation between gene
expression profiles generated by the two
methods however both platforms suffer
from background noise when attempting to
measure very low expression values
another very important similarity
between the two is that both methods are
governed by the same statistical
principles
neither platform can generate
statistically relevant data without
appropriate experimental design that
incorporates biological replicates there
is no statistical significance for a
difference measured between two samples
by either method lest both methods
suffer from biases for Michael arrange
the biases such as varied are well
understood for sequencing a much newer
method biases have been observed however
the source of these biases are not yet
well understood
micro arrays are a robust reliable
method proven over decades of use over
the years we have become comfortable
both with operating this technology and
analyzing the results although initially
a question a general consensus has
emerged on the major methods for
processing the data which can now be
performed on any PC despite dropping NGS
prices micro arrays are still more
economical and yield higher throughput
providing significant advantages when
working on a big project with a large
number of samples micro arrays are
designed with hybridization probes which
must be based on prior sequence
knowledge therefore they cannot detect
structural variations or discover novel
genes or transcripts the hybridization
strategy of micro arrays limit their
sensitivity which means they cannot
detect differences in expression between
very similar sequences such as isoforms
additionally they can only produce
relative expression levels not absolute
quantitation values
the sequencing strategy provides a
comprehensive view of the transcriptome
because it is not dependent on any prior
sequence knowledge instead every single
transcript in the sample is sequenced
known or unknown this enables the
identification of structural variations
such as gene fusions and alternative
splicing events as well as novel genes
and transcripts sequencing data can also
be reanalyzed when new discoveries are
made where as micro arrays would need to
be rerun in order to take advantage of
new sequence information
unlike micro arrays which measure probe
intensities sequencing quantifies
discrete digital read counts aligned to
a particular sequence because you are
sequencing each individual transcript
the technology is inherently more
sensitive and superior in detecting low
abundance transcripts and
differentiating biologically critical
isoforms in fact the dynamic range is
tunable and potentially unlimited
through continuous sequencing because
RNA sequencing is a cutting edge
technology it is inherently new to most
researchers and although the data output
is potentially much richer in
information this means the analysis is
much much more complex in fact
specialized computing infrastructure and
personnel are required to take advantage
of the additional biological information
in this data although there are a wealth
of tools being rapidly developed for RNA
sequencing analysis there is not yet one
standard protocol which makes comparing
results challenging sequencing generates
so much data that just storing such
large amounts of data is itself more
challenging for large file sizes they
can be difficult to share and costly to
store especially for large projects
encompassing many samples finally
despite the dropping cost of sequencing
based on current technology the cost of
performing a microarray based experiment
will be less than a comparable
sequencing based experiment in most
cases
in many instances the best strategy may
be a combination of technologies that
maximizes the effectiveness of each
while overcoming the limitations of the
other for example RNA sequencing yields
results that broadly cover all
transcripts from samples of various
temporal and spatial origins without the
need for any prior sequence knowledge
however due to the relatively higher
cost and lower throughput nature of
sample handling and data analysis the
systematic follow-through of the
sequencing discoveries for validation
and/or profiling in a reproducible
manner could take a long time and be
expensive by repetitive sequencing
custom micro arrays can be effective
follow-up tools to capture comprehensive
sequencing information and to
systematically profile and compare gene
expression based on sequencing findings
rapidly reproducibly and cost
effectively thanks for watching everyone
we hope you
this video helpful if you have any
additional questions you're welcome to
call us or even reach us via email